un jour un jour mais convoqué c'est
hervé bourges à l'époque président de
france télévisions et avec d'affilée un
matin et puis on arrive pour se faire
engueuler on avait fait une connerie
encore je sais pas quoi et on arrive
dans le bureau tous les deux face à
hervé bourges et et le président bush et
ben fille lui fait vous avez fait un
retour au président désespéré déjà on va
se faire virer
et vous avez été super cool vous êtes
gentil mais c'est vrai on ne sait pas
vrai bon je réponds excusez-moi
président prix oui quitte à l'appareil
attend c'est énorme je vous jure c'est
énorme c'est ma fille qui me dira non
parler le lot il me dit si fait un
retour acheter le pas ça c'est trop fort
il dit il vit si sarko tossée moratoire
vient d'en parler
allô oui vous avez bien j'ai dit que
vous nous manquez beaucoup ce soir parce
que je voulais dire beaucoup de bien de
vous voyez non mais c'est vrai vous êtes
gentil aussi quand toronto tout qu'est
ce que vous voulez ça m'a passé un c'est
dommage mais bon
reposez vous bien je vois que vous
faites comme tout le monde c'est la
semaine de vacances vous l'apprenez en
fait pas qu'il la prend sa semaine de
vacances se connaît oui assez verte
était à bon c'est pas mal non c'est bien
le rct nom est bon mais très bien alors
jours passent thierry alors je sais pas
si je vais lancer le téléphone non il
faut pas je vais attendre qui vient
j'aimerais bien voir ce serait le
téléphone la production s'en foutrait
mais comme c'est bien à l'eau
ah ouais les bonnes vannes oui ils
vivent les novillos mais c'est lui qui a
des renvois c'est bien en même temps
c'est la vente par téléphone c'est moins
cher j'espère c'est beaucoup moins cher
porte très bien et coûtent bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]